We've all deeply, deeply internalized the
logic of the marketplace, which is that our
value is reflected in our economic value.
This is one reason why we have otherwise very,
very smart well-intended people talking about
how to turn coal miners into software coders.
Why is it that we think that they must become
software coders?
It's because their earlier purpose in the
market no longer exists, and so we have to
find them a new one and being a software coder
seems like something that the market wants.
Now unfortunately the way that the market
is evolving is that more and more of us are
going to struggle to outcompete software,
artificial intelligence, and robots more and
more where robots are going to be to drive
a car and a truck better than us very, very
soon.
AI can already outperform the smartest doctors
at identifying tumors on a radiology film.
AI can already surpass experienced corporate
attorneys at editing documents and contracts.
And so right now we're trapped in this mindset
where we all have to find value based upon
the market's estimation of what we can do.
But the market's going to turn on more and
more of us very, very quickly and has nothing
to do with our merit.
That radiologist went to school for a long
time, but they just can't see shades of gray
that the AI can.
And the AI can reference millions of films
whereas the radiologists can only reference
thousands.
And so we have to start evolving the way we
think of ourselves and our value in this society.
If we rely upon the market, we're going to
follow the market off a cliff because the
market's going to turn on more and more of
us over time, and we can already see that
the market does not value many of the things
that are core to human existence like caring,
nurturing, and parenting and caregiving.
And I use my wife as an example.
My wife is at home with our two boys, one
of whom is autistic.
And the market values her contribution at
zero whereas we all know that's nonsense and
that her work is incredibly valuable and difficult.
It's not just the caring and nurturing roles.
It's also arts, creativity, journalism, increasingly,
volunteering in the community.
All of these things are getting valued at
zero or near zero and declining.
And so what we have to do, we have to say
look, the market is not omniscient.
The market's valuation of us and our activities
and their value is something that we essentially
invented.
And we need to invent new ways to measure
what we think is important.
And I think that this is the most important
challenge of our time because if we do not
evolve in this direction, we're going to follow
the market to a point that's going to destroy
us where eventually AI is going to be able
to outprogram our smartest software engineers.
And then what will we ask people to do that
has value?
So we have to start getting ahead of this
curve as fast as possible, and this is why
I'm running for president.